[Musique]
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
était en visite protocolaire à la villa
du département
on est en ce moment en france engagée
dans le grand débat national pour
permettre à tous les français qui le
souhaitent de faire des propositions sur
les grands enjeux qui traverse notre
pays
et moi ma mobilisation elle porte sur
les jeunes
moi je veux que les jeunes participent à
ce qu'on débat national fait beaucoup de
déplacements dans l'hexagone sur ce
sujet là et pour moi c'était essentiel
de faire un déplacement en outre-mer
pour faire un grand débat avec des
jeunes trois marins j'ai choisi la
réunion pour faire ce débat il a été
reçu par yvette duchemann conseiller
départemental et par alain armand 9e
vice président du conseil département ce
qui est important à dire c'est que c'est
pour nous l'occasion de rencontres à
nice qui est chargée de la jeunesse et
de lui dire combien il est important
d'avoir un vrai projet pour notre
jeunesse les moyens sont là elles sont
dans sa vague et insuffisant mais ce qui
est important c'est de se dire au
ministre il faut qu'il y ait vraie
volonté politique de mettre dans un pot
commun tous les moyens dont disposait la
réunion pour qu'un jeune en déshérence
ou en formation ou en création d'emplois
puissent trouver la personne qui parle
et il le moyen qu'une permettra de
réaliser son projet
[Musique]